on this monday night mourning her
majesty she met the world she was just
like everybody's grandmother thousands
converge along edinburgh's royal mile to
pay their respects to the queen one
photographer's memories of the monarch
she thought it was absolutely hilarious
and what happens to her picture on our
money and stamps plus a royal insider's
reflections on the new king he is a man
of the people he has always been a man
of the people my interview with the
queen's former press secretary
breaking news tonight a shooting in
ontario that's left two people dead
including a police officer and russia's
retreat
ukraine makes swift gains in a startling
counter-offensive
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from london
[Music]
tonight a poignant moment at st giles
cathedral in edinburgh the queen's
children standing by her coffin
surrounding it holding a vigil to their
mother while the tv cameras recorded it
millions knew her as the queen but to
her children she was a mother sadness
etched on the face of the new king
earlier for the first time members of
the public began filing past her
majesty's coffin paying their respects
hundreds of thousands are expected to do
the same in edinburgh and in london over
the coming week
[Applause]
earlier the queen's children led by king
charles walked in step and in silence
behind the hearse as it carried the
coffin along edinburgh's historic royal
mile to st giles cathedral where it will
lie in rest until tomorrow afternoon
this morning king charles invoked his
mother's spirit again as he thanked
parliament for their condolences
as shakespeare says of the earlier queen
elizabeth
she was
a pattern to all princes living
good evening from london we're
overlooking westminster abbey where the
queen's funeral will take place one week
from now over the coming days the public
will have their chance to say farewell
tonight in edinburgh an estimated 20 000
people are lining up to pay their final
respects it's become one of the largest
public events scotland has ever seen
global's crystal gomansi is there
crystal
donna people have been waiting all day
and they will be waiting all night for
the opportunity to say an up close and
personal goodbye to the queen it turns
out today goodbyes have been incredibly
difficult
a perfectly timed march with a cadence
matching the beat of the nation's
breaking heart
i've lost both my beards
not easy but when you're in the
limelight like there and they don't have
time increased quietly privately
very hard you can't help but think of
people that you've lost
tears flowed on the royal mile in
edinburgh moore wanted to be a part of
the historic scene but police officers
were forced to shut down all roads and
stairways leading to the procession
route the demand overwhelming like the
moment i feel privileged
[Music]
privileged to say goodbye to the head of
state the sovereign who uh to give the
allegiance to
it just goes to show how gracious not
just imagine the queen is
but the king
and the royal family
to allow the public
through their mother
to let the people rejoice in the
fantastic work that she did while she
was with us
[Music]
the queen's four children led by king
charles iii followed their mother's
coffin into st giles cathedral
the solid gold crown of scotland
presented to her majesty one final time
we gather to bid scotland's farewell
to our late monarch
whose life of service
to the nation and the world we celebrate
and whose love
for scotland
was legendary this is the cue to go
inside the cathedral to actually view
the coffin and pay final respects but
everyone in this massive massive line
already has a wristband there's an
entirely different line for people
looking to get their wristbands i didn't
quite enjoy queen elizabeth just from
her
determination because when she said
she'll never abdicate and she truthfully
never did so i do respect her for that
who is that paddington the paddington
bear skit from the platinum jubilee
celebration one of the last big joys
gifted to us by the queen
happy jubilee man
and
thank
you for everything
that's very kind
[Music]
[Applause]
that is such a special moment now and
people here in edinburgh will be
thinking about all kinds of different
moments as they have the opportunity
to file past the coffin until tuesday
afternoon then the princess royal will
once again accompany her mother's coffin
this time it will be flown back to
london around 8 pm arriving in london
and then that will begin the
london-based farewells donna
all right crystal commanding in
edinburgh thanks
two days ago we saw prince harry and his
wife appear alongside his brother the
prince of wales and his wife there were
greeting crowds gathered outside windsor
palace well today prince harry released
a tribute to his grandmother harry
thanked her for her sound advice and
infectious smile he described her as a
guiding compass and wrote i am forever
grateful for all our first meetings from
my earliest childhood memories to the
first moment you met my darling wife and
hugged your beloved great-grandchildren
the queen's coffin will be flown here to
london from edinburgh tomorrow and be
taken by hearst to buckingham palace
people are already camping out to try to
catch a glimpse of the queen's final
return to the palace this is the mall a
street that connects buckingham palace
and trafalgar square maria scott and six
of her friends claimed their spot on
saturday and say they plan to stay right
through to the queen's funeral next
monday
i wanted to come here to get a good
a good spot to pay me respects to her
manchester united queen
and you have got to be here early but
she gave 70 years
of ballet service to to us and 10 jesus
nothing
exact numbers are hard to predict but
it's thought more than one million
people will line up to pay their
respects to the queen as she lies in
state in london people are being told
they'll have to stand for long periods
possibly all night and will have to pass
through airport style security
the funeral for the queen will take
place monday the 19th at westminster
abbey behind me you can hear them
getting ready for it now and we'll have
live coverage as the royal family and
people from around the world say goodbye
to the longest reigning monarch in
history
we have some breaking news out of
ontario tonight a police officer has
been shot and killed peel regional
police say they responded to an incident
in mississauga ontario possibly a
carjacking this afternoon global's
brittany rosen is with me from
mississauga tonight brittany what else
are the police saying
well donna at this time police say that
there is no threat to public safety but
as you can see behind me this scene here
in mississauga which is just outside of
toronto remains incredibly active we are
in a retail shopping plaza where
multiple sources tell global news that a
toronto police officer so someone that
is not from this jurisdiction was shot
and killed and another person was rushed
to a trauma center so the scene behind
me remains again very fluid very active
we are seeing multiple officers and cop
cruisers
detectives and investigators they're
congregating by a tim hortons that is
behind me and we're paying particular
attention to a drive-through there and
you know this scene is also incredibly
large police have cordoned off a
significant portion of this retail
shopping plaza but at this hour donna
what we know so far is appeal police
were called here just after 2 p.m it was
first reported that one person was shot
but we later learned that two people
were involved in this shooting and one
of them is a toronto police officer
and it appears that this is reportedly
stemming from a carjacking that is what
multiple police sources have told global
news i can tell you donna that a person
has been arrested and police say the
suspect has now died
back to you all right brittany rosen in
mississauga tonight thanks
russian forces retreat coming up the
counter-offensive that has ukrainians
celebrating
[Music]
ukraine has mounted a swift
counter-offensive against russian forces
and within a matter of days have taken
back significant parts of the east of
the country eric sorenson explains
it has been a stunning reversal
ukrainian troops have swept into kharkiv
region sending russian troops who've
controlled the area fleeing in village
after village ukrainian fighters have
moved in welcomed by local residents
this man says the russians were here
then started shouting and running away
charging off in their tanks
the mayor of derhachi tore up the
russian flag amid cheers
the ukrainian military posted pictures
of abandoned russian tanks and equipment
it is not the first major retreat last
winter russia controlled crimea and
donetsk the start of the war saw a
military onslaught from multiple
directions eventually russians pulled
back to maintain a hold on much of
eastern ukraine but in recent days a
ukrainian counter-offensive around
kharkiv has taken back about three
thousand square kilometers of territory
according to ukraine
ukraine president zielinski addressed
the ukrainian forces saying the world is
impressed the enemy is panicking
the gains are believed to be crucial for
ukraine to maintain political support
and military supplies from its allies
it's probably the most significant
battle and moment of this war ukraine
needed to demonstrate to its western
backers the united states many european
nations canada included that it does
have a chance to win this war
in moscow the russian retreat was called
a regrouping operation
but even on russian television signs of
discontent with how the war is going
this former member of the state duma
declaring that vladimir putin was badly
advised about what could be achieved and
it could mean that the knives are coming
out for for vladimir putin right now the
fear is that putin will respond with
greater brutality
russian airstrikes destroyed a power
plant on the weekend plunging much of
kharkiv into darkness
but for now across ukraine spirits have
been lifted
after months of enduring russian
destruction in the recaptured community
of hotevka troops declare the task is
complete
erik sorensen global news toronto
the new federal conservative leader has
told his caucus he'll fight for the
working class pierre polyam claims the
liberal government is out of touch with
the struggles faced by ordinary
canadians prime minister justin trudeau
fired back accusing pauliev of
fear-mongering abigail beeman and david
aiken are standing by to unpack this for
us we begin with david in ottawa
a new leader donna and some renewed
confidence among conservative mps that
they think they have now found the
leader that can beat the trudeau
liberals in his first speech as leader
of his caucus pierre pualiev stuck to
the same messages that won him his
resounding victory saturday night we as
conservatives are always happy to work
with any party to collaborate and extend
and advance the interests of canadians
we are
but there will be no compromise on this
point conservatives will not support any
new tax increases and we will fight
tooth and nail to stop the coalition
from introducing any
the new leader of his majesty's loyal
opposition will get his first chance to
lock horns with the prime minister a
week from tuesday
i'm abigail beeman in saint andrews new
brunswick where the liberal caucus is
meeting ahead of the fall parliamentary
session and now that they know who their
main opponent will be they can better
focus as to how to gear up against the
official opposition and the prime
minister had some harsh words for his
new rival in his first public comments
since pauliev's win on saturday
buzzwords
dog whistles
and careless attacks
don't add up to a plan for canadians
attacking the institutions that make our
society
fair
safe and free
is not
responsible leadership justin trudeau
acknowledged people are struggling and
spoke about the need to focus on
building a strong economy in the face of
inflation mps are also getting ready to
head back to ottawa earlier than
expected the house sits thursday for a
special session to commemorate the
queen's passing donna
abigail thanks
ahead a one-on-one with the queen's
former press secretary his thoughts on
her cause of death
there aren't too many people who know
what it's like to be in the palace
during a crisis dickie arbiter was the
queen's press secretary for 12 years
between 1988 and 2000 and for a time he
managed the press for princess diana and
then prince charles i spoke with him
recently and started by asking him if we
know what happened to the queen in the
final days of her life
we don't know what happened
we don't know what she died of we don't
do you think we ever will know i doubt
we ever will
and
she seemed bright as a button when she
met liz truss her brain was razor sharp
always razor sharp and
she had that lovely radiant smile even
sparkling it was terrific and then
shortly thereafter she sent a message to
canada governor general over the
killings in saskatchewan
and that was her last message but we
don't know what happened
are you surprised by the number of
people who have turned out along that
route in scotland queen was loved
the queen was respected she'd been with
us a long time and the majority of
people in the united kingdom didn't know
anybody else didn't know other any other
sovereign i was born in 1940 so i
remember when the king died in 1952 i
remember the coronation i remember when
the then princess elizabeth first rode
out on trooping the color i was seven at
the time so i've got all these memories
and here we are again
reliving those memories because another
sovereign has passed on it must be quite
something for you personally
it is something for me personally having
worked for her for 12 years and having
been i'm a monarchist i believe in the
monarchy i don't think there's any other
alternative with a queen or a king like
the queen 70 years on the throne it was
continuity she had respect not just the
uk but global respect global respect in
her realm states like canada queen of
canada
did you take us back to uh
what it might have been like what you
think it might have been like in the
palace when it became clear that the
queen
was dying or perhaps it already died
well the palace don't panic
one thing um it was very clear that the
queen
uh was not a hundred percent well not a
hundred percent fit
and it wasn't a question of if but when
so plans would have been taken out of
the
dust blown off
and they would have start making
arrangements
we can hear the work going on right near
us now we're right near the houses of
parliament this whole area i expect will
be flooded with people right for the
lying in state people will be so anxious
to try to pay their respects
well king george the sixth in 1952 was
well over 400 000 people i would have
thought probably
if they manage it properly um that in
probably in excess of a million people
will go through in the uh in the four
days
everybody will want to go if go judging
by what's been happening at buckingham
palace people most certainly will want
to go and pay their respects because it
is history it is living history as you
watch the transition from
prince charles to king charles iii what
did you what did you make of
how he his demeanor how he
has handled things at least from a
public perspective the king got
everything
absolutely 101 right
back in london
the car stopped short of the north
central gate of buckingham palace he and
the queen consort got out they did a
walkabout they talked to mourners
they were very relaxed they were smiling
and it was striking just the right chord
he is a man of the people he has always
been a man of the people so what he did
outside buckingham palace was absolutely
spot on when he went in
and he gave his television address that
too was pitch perfect
he said all the right things he felt
them
he talked about his mama
he talked about her
joining his his beloved father
so
it was a perfect address
so yeah he is getting stuck in and doing
what is to be done so the transition is
is smooth
that's that's how the monarchy works
there isn't a gap the queen is dead long
live the king that's how it works the
royal standard never comes down because
the sovereign is always alive
dickie arbiter thank you thank you
next the priceless story behind the
queen's portrait you probably have in
your wallet
[Music]
the queen was the most photographed
woman in the world captured on iphones
and by official photographers most often
during formal events but in intimate
moments with her family too and her
image of course is everywhere on money
stamps and countless other items across
the commonwealth so what happens to all
that now
jeff semple went to find out
her face is perhaps the most
photographed in history
and some of the most iconic images of
queen elizabeth ii were snapped by ian
jones
over 30 years the royal photographer
captured countless moments from around
the world but one image in particular is
distinctly canadian so canadians know
this picture very well yes they may not
know that you took this photograph
possibly not no they know who's on it
in 2012 jones was invited to buckingham
palace to take a photo of the queen for
canada's new twenty dollar bill but when
the queen arrived jones realized the
office chair they'd prepared was much
too tall so when she sat down in the
chair her toes just about to touch the
floor
um and
the tip-toe it's a little skip around so
she ended up rotating on her toes with
this glint in her eye and she thought it
was absolutely hilarious but what it did
prompt was a wonderful glint and a smile
and that really set the tone for the
portrait session the queen's image and
mark are ubiquitous found on everything
from post boxes and stamps to flags and
t-tins and the ascension of a new
monarch will now require a major royal
rebranding
the british national anthem has now
changed back to god save the king new
currency featuring charles's portrait
will be produced after his coronation
but it'll likely be a while before he
gives his mother a run for her money the
queen's image is featured on coins
across the commonwealth at one time she
appeared on 33 different currencies the
most of any monarch we have a series of
coins over her record reign her image
was updated five times charting her
evolution as sovereign so now for the
first time ever in most of our lives
we're going to see more than one monarch
on the coins of the realm and the same
goes for stamps this profile first
issued in 1966 has been reproduced 320
billion times more than any artwork in
history the uk will now stop producing
these stamps but like the queen's
currency they'll still be accepted they
will fall out of circulation slowly but
i imagine the coins of elizabeth will be
circulating for many decades to come her
reign is over but will carry her with us
for years to come jeff semple global
news london
that is global national for this monday
from overlooking westminster abbey in
london i'm donna friesen preparations
are well underway here for the state
funeral on monday that will attract
leaders from all over the world and it's
expected a multitude of other people
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye
[Music]
you